Fatima naroli escaped fighting between
Sudan's Army and Rapid support forces in
Khartoum she gave birth in harsh
conditions when she arrived in wadmedani
southeast of the Sudanese Capital then
God we are now safe I was pregnant and
in my last month and it was impossible
for us to stay at home
the fighting has forced almost 3 million
Sudanese from their homes
more than a hundred and fifty thousand
families are in Jazeera state
they're in temporary shelters or living
with local families
civil organizations and local activists
work day and night to provide basic
needs
the state directed us not to open camps
for the displace the government along
with charitable organizations can manage
but it will put us under a lot of
pressure
this school has been turned into a
shelter for more than 60 families
through play and activity the children
are trying to overcome the trauma and
harsh conditions in health clinics
volunteers work to provide food drinking
water and medical care to as many as
possible
up to 40 000 people who have fled the
conflict are also here in Port Sudan and
they are being helped by relief
organizations
the Russia charity is one of the local
organizations trying to accommodate the
displaced civilians
we're doing a lot of things to help a
large number of families here in our
work at Refugee centers we provide meat
we're running entertainment programs for
children and giving them toys and we'll
continue our charity programs with our
team
with limited funding and an enormous
task to cope with local charities are
struggling but not without dedication
and resolve Muhammad Val Al Jazeera Port
Sudan